welcome back to Durango electric culture
in this episode we want you to keep
planting wow look at these
poppies Teragon look at that okay you
take your
Teragon rip it
open and then look at all those little
tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny seeds
just
uh just spread them out all over the
place open up another
one and keep planting uh when the seeds
are so tiny it's good to use like the
entire flat that way uh you can get it
oh yeah and once the seeds are down you
want want to be spraying it to keep them
down and you know water them up be nice
to
them it's a good thing to do and then of
course I check on oh eth inch deep yeah
there we
go next up dill look at that all
right here's your seed
pods few here few there
you
everywhere all right and after that of
course you want to soak them
down I want to get these good because
the seed pods
are have a tendency to dry
out and then you know the
usual cover them up everything's growing
so fast let's show you all about it May
25th May 30th
May
25th May
30th again May
25th and this morning May
31 thanks for watching we'll see you
next time